what's going on guys this is rob and uh
this is our easter eggs video for moon
knight in fact there's actually two huge
easter eggs in this movie that people
are talking about one and as far as i
can tell nobody really seems to be
talking about the other which is kind of
astounding to me because it basically
connects black panther to moon knight
but a lot of the easter eggs that are
out there are pretty straightforward
right so like donna the woman that steve
grant works for is basically modeled
after donna craft who is uh the the
publicist of steve grant for steve corp
which is basically the company that
stephen grant runs in order to fund his
role as moon knight for those of you
guys who don't know when it comes to the
three personalities of mark spector um
there was basically originally just mark
spector himself and that was it right he
was a mercenary and like like a soldier
of fortune that kind of a thing and then
after he became moon knight you kind of
had two personalities where you had mark
specter then you had moon knight
eventually mark developed the identity
of stephen grant which originally was
not a disassociative identity instead it
was just a fake identity that he had
fabricated in order to create a
legitimate business and then have that
business fund his moon knight endeavors
following that he made a another
identity called jake lockley which again
did not start off as a disassociative
identity instead it was just a fake id
that he would use in order to be on the
street level and to hear what was going
on when it came to crime on the street
level eventually because of the fact
that he kept intertwining between these
different identities right jumping back
and forth between pretending to be steve
grant pretending to be jake lockley
pretending to be mark spector or at
least just being mark spector as well as
operating uh as moon knight in addition
to like all the crazy endeavors that
konchu put him through they all started
merging until he got to the point where
mark spector didn't know
which one or which history was actually
him because he gave them all histories
they all have their own histories their
own stories origins parents the whole
nine yards right like they they had
their own like their own identities and
so that's where the disassociative
identity kicks in is because it was
basically mark losing track of his fake
ids and then ultimately absorbing them
and then creating actual identities in
his mind out of those characters and so
having said that yeah the character of
donna is basically the publicist for
steven grant in the comics right and so
it's kind of interesting that she
basically or that stephen grant works
for her because as it stands now in the
moon night show steven grant is not like
a millionaire like he's not super rich
like he is in the comics he's just a guy
who works at a gift shop um and so we
haven't really seen the jake lockley
persona yet i don't know if we will uh
what we do get at least as far as the
the ground level element is we get
bertrand crawley that was basically the
guy who was in the golden statue or who
was pretending to be a golden statue
that's the guy that feeds information to
mark spector or moon knight or mr knight
or whatever identity he's using um in
order to kind of go forward and maintain
his role as a superhero and then or a
vigilante and then deal with different
criminal elements that he otherwise
wouldn't have known about had it not
been for the information of crawley now
the other cool thing here is that
because of the fact that the two of them
basically talk it looks like it's more
than a conversation of like them just
talking like him just talking to this
guy who is a golden statue like he
literally brings him a burrito and he
was like here's the same burrito as
always so essentially or maybe a wrap i
don't know it's he brought him food
right and it seemed to be his favorite
food so seemingly the two of them have
had conversations in the past even if it
was just because of the fact that you
know crawley was getting ready for his
gig where he goes out there and
entertains the masses or whatever it is
but it looks like the involvement
between the two stretches beyond simply
just steven grant talking to a guy who
pretends to be a statue in a park right
i mean
given this dude's
life
it sounds like something he would do
[Laughter]
but it sounds like there's a little more
to it than that there's also a few other
easter eggs where like steve grant
missed the bus and so like he's racing
to catch it and on one of the buildings
it says atlantis so people are taking
that as like a nod to name on the
submariner but what's what's really
really cool when it comes to these
easter eggs it's really really important
here is one latviria and black panther
now here's the reason why i say this
when we're first introduced to arthur
harrow and i'm not talking about like
the opening scene when he puts glass in
his shoes which is actually a nod to the
fact that in the comics arthur herrera
was a guy who was obsessed with pain
this it was crazy man so like here's the
thing when arthur harrow has first
introduced one of the craziest stories
when arthur harrow is first introduced
moon knight basically ends up on this
island where like these experiments are
being conducted on people and he's like
investigating and trying to understand
what's going on because there's like a
person who escapes i want to say he's on
vacation and then while he's on vacation
he's like like there's just some person
running through like you know being
rounded up or whatever it is he's like
okay we gotta investigate this this guy
arthur harold he basically suffered from
a degenerative illness where he felt
pain all the time and so the idea was
twofold one to basically cure his own
illness insofar as finding a way to
basically use block the the
neurotransmitters for pain and two it
could actually be weaponized and used by
like corporations to kind of create
super soldiers right kind of again this
ongoing theme that always happened in
marvel comics that following the death
of captain america that there was this
mad dash by like scientists and like the
government and weapons plus all that
kind of stuff to find a way to create
super soldiers right that's why i say
like with captain america that pandora's
box was open right like as soon as it
was it was literally like steve rogers
getting the super soldier serum becoming
a super soldier everybody wanted to make
their own variation of it but regardless
the scene that i'm referencing with
regards to the introduction of arthur
harrow is like when you actually see him
basically judging people because of what
amit wants right judging their hearts to
see what they have done what they're
currently doing or what they will do and
whether or not it's evil and then of
course killing them based on what's
going to happen uh that whole sequence
right like literally the that sequence
from that point running to the point
when mark has the cupcake truck and
disappoints us all by not eating one uh
and like all those things right like all
that takes place in latvia that's the
on-running theory and that's i think
that's true because i feel like if it
wasn't latviria and just some random
town they probably would have given it a
name they probably would have been like
this is the town he's in right even if
it was just like some words up in the
top right or top left hand corner of the
screen it would have told us where he
was at now the more obvious question
here that a lot of non-comic book
readers would probably ask is if that's
latviria which is where dr doom resides
and he's in that giant castle that you
saw off in the distance
why didn't he do anything to stop all
this madness that was going on in his
town where there's like a shootout and
people are dying and everything like
that well there's a couple reasons why
the first is because one dr doom is
notoriously reclusive like you you hear
about stories where he goes out and he
fights a fantastic four or something
along those lines but unless he's
involved in some kind of a campaign that
could potentially be a threat to
latviria or could boost his own power he
doesn't care he never leaves castle
doomstat right even his son christopher
bernard never leaves castle doomsday
like they never go out into the general
public and the reason why is because
doctor doom kind of sees himself as
being above the people but at the same
time exists to protect the people again
this was really highlighted and jonathan
hickman's avengers news this was really
highlighting that story when he was
talking to neymar the submariner and he
was talking about how like like if the
people in liberia really wanted to
destroy him uh does doctor doom think
that they wouldn't do it and dreams like
no they could kill me if they wanted to
right like i i would not kill my own
people he's like i would die before i
let my people die he's like but i keep
them protected i keep them safe i keep
them fed right i keep them watered i
make their life better right i give them
a life and a home here and so he's like
before they give thanks to whatever god
they believe in when they go to bed at
night they give thanks to me right i
mean it's the most arrogant statement
ever but that's how dr doom sees himself
in relation to his people he's like a
parent right kind of like this guiding
force but he doesn't get himself
involved in every single skirmish
because by and large the people of
latvia are very tough and hardened
people they'll keep themselves protected
so if this arthur hero guy has like 20
people surrounding him and they see him
as somebody who is believable or
somebody that has like this kind of
almost mystical nature about him make no
mistake they do not worship him
they worship dr doom this is just a guy
they're very intrigued with at the
moment but if you were for example to
say that like that begins to grow and
like it turns into this thing where the
people love arthur harrow so much they
actually start to lose faith in doctor
doom and focus on arthur hero doctor
doom would likely step in either that or
it would turn into like some kind of
religious civil war between the people
who are faithful to dr doom and the
people who are not faithful to doctor
doom and then of course doctor doom
would step in and probably kill off
arthur herrera right just whisk him away
and just be like do not forget who keeps
you fed right do not forget who takes
care of you and then like go back to
castle doom uh because that's the thing
like nine times out of ten whenever you
see doctor doom in marvel comics it's
usually a doombot right one of the
robots he's made that looks exactly like
him and the robots are designed to
actually believe they are him so that no
one can tell the difference between a
doombot and the actual victor von doom
so that's probably why he wouldn't
necessarily have gotten involved there
but that that location that whole area
looks exactly like liberia like it looks
exactly like liberia in the comics we'll
put a panel up here right we will put if
we haven't already we will put a comic
book depiction of latvia up here and
tell me it doesn't look the same right
like tell me it does not look like that
a giant castle off in the distance a
little village or kind of a bigger
village right a little kingdom area
where you know it looks exactly like it
does in the show right so that looks
like latviria i'm pretty sure it is and
if it is it's a very smart move not to
invoke its name and it's a very smart
move not to have like pictures of doctor
doom all over the place so like you know
that he's there it's just one of those
small little teasers it gets people
talking but as far as the other big
easter egg here goes right let's talk
about khanu for a second and his
connection to the panther god best so
kanchu and bast and a lot of those
others are what we call new gods in
marvel comics at least not everybody i
do right i mean technically i call them
new gods and then you have the elder
gods so the way this worked you know
we're going to kind of take a page out
of the comic books here and focus on the
comics and this this instance and of
course we also covered this in our video
explaining the the history of konshu in
marvel comics over comics explain if you
guys are interested in seeing that but
the the way this worked is that what you
had at least one of the explanations in
terms of how life originated on earth is
you had a being that was referred to as
the demiurge now the divi urge was
basically the sentient manifestation of
the earth's biosphere right basically
life itself on earth and that what it
did is it went through and basically
created the elder gods as well as
planting the seeds of what would
eventually become like humans and
animals and different things along those
lines now these elder gods were wide and
varying you guys have already heard of
some of them so people like cathone
right he's an example of it but where
the elder gods were simply just created
by the demiurge over time they basically
went nuts and they ended up just
becoming like these really evil twisted
versions of themselves so much so that
they were basically tormenting life on
earth and then fighting each other vying
for power and so what ended up happening
is the only member of the elder gods who
was not corrupted was gaia basically the
sentience of mother earth as well as the
the biological mother of thor and so
what ended up going on is that she went
to the demi urge and asked the demiurge
to give her the ability to give birth to
a being powerful enough to defeat the
elder gods and allow life on earth to
flourish this basically meant that the
demiurge impregnated her with a being
named a tomb a tomb eventually became
the demi gorge and literally a tomb went
through and killed virtually every
single one of the elder gods the only
ones that didn't die were the ones who
fled so you're talking about basically
the octescence right so like cedar rack
and those guys and then you talk about
people like like cathone and so on and
so forth they all basically bailed and
so the results of this is that now they
all exist in their own individual
dimensions and that once a tomb had
destroyed them all a tomb took off went
into the sun and then became the first
in a in an age of new gods calling
himself almond raw right this is the
egyptian sun god and so what this did is
it led to uh to a tomb basically giving
birth to all kinds of like a new
generation of gods uh marvel never
really specifies if like the norse
pantheon of gods are tied into a tomb
and in fact there's no reason to believe
they are
their history actually seems to predate
the idea of a tomb in the sense that
like they've been part of the cycle of
ragnarok the birth and death of asgard
like over and over and over again right
the the idea of a tomb insofar as this
age of new gods seems largely confined
to the idiot basically the pantheon of
egyptian gods and so what this does is
it leads into well really it brings in a
tomb it's something that's referred to
as the sky fathers so a tomb is
basically a member of of the council of
godhead so like a tomb zeus um odin
vishnu like all those different uh quote
unquote heads of like the godly
pantheons that exist from different
cultures around the world a tomb is a
part of those but the thing about this
is that among these various egyptian
gods you got konchu and you got bast
vast originally started out as an
egyptian god but when the first uh the
first member of wakanda the first person
in wakanda bashinga i think it was
basically encountered the vibranium
meteorite and then prayed to basically
find protection for it that led to bast
actually defecting from the egyptian
pantheon of gods and then traveling to
wakanda and becoming what was in effect
the patron saint of the wakandan panther
clan basically the panther clan derives
all their power from bast and so that's
how bass ended up becoming the uh
basically the panther god of wakanda but
she is the offspring of a tomb or almond
raw and so is konchu and so as a result
of that they are in effect family
they're connected right brothers it's
kind of weird like bast is depicted to
us as both a male and a female it
changes based on who's telling the story
more often than not bast appears as
basically just like a giant panther but
if you go and you read like jonathan
hickman's fantastic four or any of the
stories written by jonathan hickman
black panther t'challa always refers to
bast as goddess and in fact there is a
point in hickman's fantastic four when
basically t'challa goes on to become the
king of the dead after having to give up
the black panther mantle to shuri that
he ends up basically meeting with bast
who is in a humanoid form and looks like
a woman right like vast has female
features uh whereas if you look in other
comics over the years of marvel comics
uh bass has just been referred to as god
right the god of the panther clan so
again you know it's kind of nebulous in
terms of whether or not bass is like
male or female and in the end it doesn't
really matter right i mean it's just
it's a powerful being who exists out
there but nonetheless i thought it was
kind of cool like that's something
really really cool whether or not we'll
see any connection between bast and
konshu in the moonlight show has yet to
be seen i imagine we'll probably get
some kind of a segment in the show that
will give us like this lineage of you
know kind of like this long-form
discussion of like the different
egyptian gods that are out there and if
ever we were going to see a connection
between kanchu and bast that's when we
would get it and i think they will i
think they'll be like you know from
almond raw came these new this new age
of gods and goddesses among them was
consu and bast and people are gonna be
like best
from like wakanda and it's like yes
you know i'm really excited to see what
direction this goes in but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace